because some figures have come in are
there the UK figures and as of 9 a.m. on
the 7th of April 266,000 694 tests have
concluded with 14,000 and 6 tests on the
6th of April 213,000 181 people have
been tested of which 55,000 242 were
positive and as of 5:00 p.m. on the 6th
of April of those hospitalized in the UK
who tested positive 6000 159 have sadly
died let's join Ashish Joshi in the sky
news room so Ashley just talk us through
these figures the figures the the rise
the cumulative total rise the 6 1 5 9
the 1 you can see the the last column
the bottom figure there that's up from
yesterday which was 5000 373 you know
every day we talk about that the tally
between England Wales Scotland and
Northern Ireland and we explained that
there is a lag in in the way that the
figures are collected and compiled so
somebody sitting at home who might have
been following today's figures they
would have realised that in England
today we had 758 deaths reported Wales
as 19 big jump in Scotland which I'll
explain in just a minute of 74 deaths
and Northern Ireland three more to the
total there the reason why that column
of figures might not necessarily add up
to the 6 1 5 9 is just because of the
time frame and the way these figures are
collected across these four nations and
then presented as a cumulative total by
the Department of Health and Social Care
so that figure there the 6 1 5 9 that
would mean that the the rate that we're
following here the doubling rate is
still at about just around the 3.5 some
people might look at that and say it's
optimistic that shows that that curve is
flattening but then other people would
say it's too early to say we are
approaching the peak that's predicted to
be around four or five days from now we
don't know I mean it might not be four
or five days but certainly that's what
the the data is suggesting that once we
hit the peak
we'll know whether the social distancing
and the lockdown has had an impact the
argument from the government is that it
is still too early to start softening
the lockdown but certainly they will be
keeping an eye on these figures and
hoping that the the the doubling rates
the number of people who are confirmed
dead does start to increase so it's it
and which it has been doing if you
follow the trend over the last couple of
weeks